hi welcome to the monitor I am Peter
Reuben senior editor of Wired magazine
this week we're going to talk about
prometheus we're going to talk about a
couple of video games that turn your
world upside down but first we are going
to talk about a comic book specifically
mind management it came out on Dark
Horse Comics a couple of weeks ago it's
by a guy named matt kindt who's done a
couple of other great books in the past
it's about a mind control agency that's
shrouded in darkness and secrecy Matt
did the art and the writing himself and
it's kind of chock full of codes and
puzzles and there's a little bit for
readers to tease out on their own
actually before you read number one
which just came out is going back to our
course actually released three free
prequel episodes called mine management
the secret files and they kind of give
you a good backdrop a little bit of
context for issue one so it's not quite
as oblique as it might be otherwise
definitely worth checking out so get it
through the Dark Horse app or at your
local comic book shop let's talk about
these video games I promised we're going
to go to my correspondent in the field
all right thank you so I am at e3 this
week and III is kind of a strange time
to release a video game because everyone
who really cares about video games
concentrating more on the news of video
games that will be coming out yet Namco
and saber interactive are finally
releasing inversion which was supposed
to be out earlier this year got delayed
for graphic polish reasons and player
experience reasons but is finally out it
is a sci-fi third person shooter
adventure game in which you are able to
invert gravity hence the whoa hence the
clever name this is weird it sorry lil
woozy played it last year it's changed a
lot since then probably visually as well
but there's fun to be had not saying
it's a must buy I am saying it's worth a
little time some r tends to be a little
foul for video games to check it out
rent it gamefly if you like it buy it
but that's not the only game that's out
next week Gravity Rush is coming out but
only for the PlayStation Vita so if you
have a PS Vita you're in luck
you don't have a PS Vita then you are
like most people in the world but
gravity rush is arguably one of the best
titles to come out for the unit so far
it is an adventure game with a big
puzzle element in which you are able to
control gravity within the game using
either the fancy Jai ramadhar gyroscope
II thing in the PS Vita or using your
traditional button interface now it
actually reminds me a little bit in a
weird way of Fez which came out a couple
of months ago fantastic Fez for the xbox
live arcade in which you kind of get
through levels and solve puzzles by
putting a spin on things and getting a
different perspective gravity rush works
much the same way and really is a lot of
fun and has a great kind of manga ish
influence um being Japanese that's not
so surprising but anyway I'm gonna try
and figure out what's wrong with my
semicircular canals back to you okay
thanks for that I think so prometheus is
out this week and as you well know or as
I hope you well know it is the prequel
to Ridley Scott's alien universe in
particular he's he's back this time
which is great directing the movie the
movie was actually co-written by damon
lindelof who was so heavily involved
with lost throughout its run but
prometheus kind of goes back a number of
years and sets into motion the events
that found us so screwed on board the
Nostromo in in the first alien movie and
then the events that of course played
throughout it's been getting kind of
mixed a mixed reception among critics at
least but fam seemed to really love it
and you got to go in with your eyes open
Ridley Scott created two of the most
fantastic and enduring universes in 80
sci-fi being of course alien and and
Blade Runner and and from the look of it
this really deserves a shot in fact I'm
going to give it my haiku review of the
week Ridley's world is back and I'm
excited even if faas bender stays closed
no disappointing even for me but that's
it for the monitor so come back next
week where we're going to have all the
best in pop culture as always but until
then inspirational catchphrase here
you